[Musik]
nach umfassender Kritik einer gasumlage
will Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert
Habeck die gasumlage reformieren sie
werde nun an Bedingungen wie keine
Bonuszahlung an den Vorstand geknüpft
werden Bundeskanzler Scholz verspricht
zeitnah weitere Entlastung für die
Bürger bereitzustellen und eine neue
Studie der DRK zeigt das im zweiten
Corona ja 54 Prozent mehr Mädchen im
Alter von 15 bis 17 Jahren erstmalig
eine Essstörung entwickelt haben und
damit herzlich Willkommen zu viertel
nach acht meine Gäste heute Abend sind
linken Politiker Lorenz göster Beutin
sein Thema Deckel auf Strom und Gas
finanziert werden soll das durch die
übergewinnsteuer wir das argumentiert
ich bin gespannt nzz-pulli Redakteur
Alexander Kistler 0 Euro Bahnticket
nicht mit ihm er sagt es gibt kein Recht
auf kostenlos Kayan özgen Chefredakteur
von Business Insider ärgert der
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk er hat
auch ein Buch geschrieben weil sie ihn
gleich zeige aber heute Abend ist seine
tesi erstmal Tatort ARD es ist Zeit für
eine echte Reform des öffentlich-
gleichen Rundfunks last but not least
Rechtsanwalt Udo Vetter erst Fachanwalt
für Strafrecht und hadert mit dem
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das ist das wo
man sich immer entscheiden kann ob mein
Mann oder Frau ist er wird es gleich
noch mal erklären das neue Gesetz könnte
dramatische Folgen haben und hier möchte
ich Ihnen einmal noch das Buch empfehlen
von unserem Gast macht und Millionen ist
auch ein toller Podcast hören Sie doch
mal rein aber vor allem kaufen Sie das
Buch und mein Name ist Lena Schink und
ich freue mich heute Abend ihre
Gastgeberin sein zu dürfen mein Aufreger
des Tages ist heute kein Aufreger
sondern eine Bitte ein Autor des
englischen telegrams hat die
corona-maßnahmen Kritiker um
Entschuldigung gebeten ich finde das
großartig und bitte darum dass wir uns
in Deutschland an den telegraf-auto ein
Beispiel nehmen wir brauchen eine
massive corona-entschuldigungswelle im
deutschen Journalismus der Grund wie
andere Meinungen hierzulande bei vielen
Medien bei vielen Journalisten in den
letzten Jahren ausgegrenzt wurde war
einfach nicht richtig man darf Fehler
machen aber ich finde dann sollte man
sich entschuldigen eine kurze Kostprobe
weil mit zwei Statements der ARD
Journalist Reinhard Becker sagte Zitat
all diesen Spinnern und corona-kritikern
sei gesagt es wird keine Normalität mehr
geben wie vorher
rtl-politikchef Nikolaus Blome ging
sogar noch weiter als er sagte ich
hingegen möchte an dieser Stelle
ausdrücklich um gesellschaftliche
Nachteile für all jene ersuchen die
freiwillig auf eine Impfung verzichten
möge die gesamte Republik mit dem Finger
auf sie zeigen
wann haben politische Maßnahmen jemals
diesen Beifall erhalten und können
Regelungen und pharmazeutische Produkte
überhaupt die jemals so gut sein dass es
seitens Journalismus so wenig wie in den
letzten zweieinhalb Jahren kritisiert
wurde verstehen Sie mich hier bitte
nicht falsch die Pandemie über eine
wirklich schwierige Zeit weder Regierung
noch Journalismus sind unfehlbar und die
entspannt hatte recht als er sagte wir
werden einander viel verzeihen müssen
aber dafür muss man ja auch erstmal um
Entschuldigung bitten einer der hier in
der Runde sitzt hat da nicht mitgemacht
er ist sehr oft für die Persönlichkeit
eingetreten Alexander Kistler meine
Frage ist kam es denn nur mir so vor
oder hatten wir den letzten zweieinhalb
Jahren Probleme in der deutschen
Berichterstattung was die
corona-pandemie betrifft ich glaube man
muss da zumindest zwei Phasen
unterscheiden am Anfang das haben sie
auch angedeutet wusste man ja wirklich
nicht wo es lang geht ein neuer Virus
von China herkommt fällt über die Welt
her stirbt man daran wer stirbt daran
was macht man dagegen da habe ich
vollstes Verständnis dass man da
wirklich im Team vorsicht war das war
ich auch am Anfang ich war auch
sorgenvoll ich habe auch Nächte lang
schlecht geschlafen ich hatte einmal
Angst das Wasser auf meinen Kopf regnete
weil ich dachte wenn das kontaminiert
ist dann sterbe ich jetzt also völlig
hysterisch aber dann gab es einen
Impfstoff dann gab es doch ziemlich
wirksame Maßnahmen und dann hat man
rhetorisch in dem Moment als es wirklich
auf dem Weg war in den Griff zu bekommen
die ganze Pandemie rhetorisch
aufgerüstet ich habe noch mal
nachgeguckt man hat auch in der Zeit zum
Beispiel plädoys geschrieben wir
brauchen Ausgrenzung wir müssen ein Keil
Treiben in die Gesellschaft zwischen den
die ein Risiko sind und die dann Risiko
verursachen wir hatten ganz schlimme
Aussagen in der Politik zum Beispiel der
rheinland-pfälzische Gesundheitsminister
von der SPD hat gesagt wer sich nicht
wird impfen lassen muss damit rechnen
dass man ihn ganz genau beobachtet dass
ihn totalitäre überwachungsfantasien das
sind autoritäre redeweisen die an der
Gesellschaft nichts zu tun haben dürfen
die sonst für Toleranz für ihre
Augenhöhe berühmt ist und oft auch
zurecht berühmt ist und ich finde man
müsste zumindest erkennen dass man da
rhetorisch fairere mehrere Kilometer
übers Ziel hinausgeschossen ist das
betrifft genauso die Politik wie auch
die Journalisten Journalismus muss
generell von Ausnahmen abgesehen Kritik
sein am Regierung und wir haben in
dieser corona-phase in der ersten Phase
zumindest applaudierende Journalisten
gestanden die also praktisch den
Lorbeerkranz auf dem Haupt von Frau
Merkel damals von Herr Lauterbach später
abgesetzt haben das darfst du nicht sein
wir müssen aus dieser Ausgrenzung lernen
und für die künftigen Debatten und
Konflikte Energiekrise Stichwort lernen
andere Menschen nicht ausgrenzen weil
sie andere Meinung haben und der
Eigenverantwortung auch etwas mehr
Vertrauen als der regierungsdirektiv
aber ist ja nicht die Kritikfähigkeit
der Journalisten jetzt stark gestiegen
also ich habe das Gefühl ich habe schon
da sehr viel viele viele Medien jetzt
schon deutlich kritischer darauf schauen
und nicht mehr so in diesen Applaus
reingehen wie es am Anfang dafür ja aber
das ist jetzt ja wir sagen auf der
allerletzten Runde wir sind jetzt glaube
ich hier im im dritten sogenannten
Corona Herbst und die Zahlen gehen ja
wirklich überall runter und wenn man
jetzt noch das gleiche macht aber ich
vermisse wirklich da muss ich Ihnen
Recht geben
wir haben ja auch immer Sachen wo die
Politik kennen ja gar nicht aus dem
entschuldigen raus wir kamen ja gleich
noch die gasumlage und die
konstruktionist aber und entschuldigung
aber wir haben eine Situation gehabt wie
Sie richtig sagen die in der Bedrohung
war die eine Krisensituation war die
eine Pandemie war und es ging um die
Frage wie retten wir Menschenleben weil
wir dürfen es ja nicht
missverstehen wir hatten ja eine
Situation wo das erste Virus die erste
Variante wirklich mega gefährlich war
Krankenkassen Journalismus die
Berichterstattung ausgewogen ausgewogen
weiß nicht ich finde fand schwierig von
vielerlei Seiten wo teilweise echt
Überspitzungen waren wo man eine
Spaltung hatte wo es auch er
Schlagzeilen der Bild-Zeitung gab die so
polemisiert haben dass sie mit zurzeit
auch bei getragen haben
teilweise ging da Sachen gegen ihren
Lauterbach oder auch Herrn Drosten wo
ich sagen ist das ist das ist halt
drüber das muss man halt nicht machen in
so einer Krisensituation
aber das Wichtige ist dass ich bei
vielen Menschen wahrgenommen habe das
wirklich darum gerungen wird mit dieser
Krise klar zu kommen und das ist das
zentrale für mich und ich was ich
wichtig finde ist wirklich treffende
Kritik anzubringen also ich bin nicht
irgendwie mich entschuldigen bei
irgendwelchen Leuten die mit
schwarz-weiß-roten Fahnen auf die Straße
gegangen sind es war noch nicht alle
demonstrieren
deswegen sage ich ja ich glaube es ist
richtig wenn wir aus dieser Spaltung
rauskommen wenn wir eine sachliche
Diskussion am kommen aber wir brauchen
keine
entschuldigungsorgien ich habe ein Tweet
von ihnen mitgebracht heute abend weil
sie mir gerade Spaltung angesprochen und
eine Spaltung die sie glaube ich auch
ganz also nehme ich nun positiv an war
2G ich glaube es war eine Maßnahme für
die sie waren wenn ich den Tweet lese
und zwar haben sie nämlich getwittert
sie waren also sie haben getwitter die
aktuelle Notlage ist komplett
überflüssig unnötig wäre mit einer hohen
Impfquote zu vermeiden gewesen wenn
jetzt SPD und FDP eine Impfpflicht
ausschließen ist das fahrlässig ist es
eine Themen die sie heute noch teilen
das werden Impfpflicht brauchen ich
glaube wir hatten eine Situation wo eine
Impfpflicht eine notwendige und richtige
Maßnahme gewesen wäre in der Hochzeit
ich glaube das war der Herbst
2020 2021 genau
hatten und wo klar war dass man
sozusagen mit dem Impfen da rauskommt
aus dieser Situation da hatten wir eine
vorige Variante die extrem gut
angesprochen hat auf diesen Impfstoff
das haben wir jetzt bei diesem
Omegon Variante nicht in dem Maße und zu
dem Zeitpunkt hätte ich das richtig am
gefunden um aus diesem Lockdown aus
dieser bedrängungssituation beim
rauszukommen weil Menschen können sich
trotzdem gegenseitig anstecken also
geimpfte und ungeimpfte konnten sich
gegenseitig anstecken egal wie der
Impfstoff Impfstatus war bei dieser
Variante hatten wir noch eine andere
Situation und eine andere Studienlage ja
die Impfung 100%ige Immunisierung
versprochen hundertprozentige nicht aber
die Möglichkeit der Übertragung war zu
dem Zeitpunkt im wesentlich geringer
haben die Studien damals gezeigt zu dem
Zeitpunkt bei der Variante das war Delta
damals hat euch natürlich Impfpflicht
immer eine ganz scharfes Mittel das wenn
Sie auch wissen natürlich Florist und da
muss man glaube ich etwas vorsichtiger
mit umgehen mit diesem Mittel ich bin
auch dafür dass man darüber diskutiert
dass man vor allem den und es hat daran
hat ja damals gelegen wir hatten ja
nicht genug Impfstoff für die die sich
impfen lassen wollten und hat dann schon
darüber gesprochen die sie sich nicht
impfen lassen wollten zu zwingen sich zu
impfen also völlig absurde Situation
aber ein Impfpflicht ist zumal ein sehr
scharfer Eingriff in die körperliche
Unversehrtheit mit
Selbstbestimmungsrecht über den eigenen
Körper den wir sonst sehr hoch halten
und ich habe zu keinem Zeitpunkt der
Pandemie dieses Schwelle für für
überschritten gehabt hätte es
wahrgenommen bin ich als Medienkonsument
mal das Revue passieren lasse was in den
letzten zwei Jahren passiert ist muss
ich sagen es gibt einfach eine
Legitimationskrise des deutschen
Journalismus mittlerweile weil eben
nicht das ganze aber eines großen Teils
des Journalismus will jetzt keine Namen
nennen aber er es wurde viel von oben
erklärt aber nicht sachlich sondern es
wurde behauptet ihr müsst das und das
machen das ist alternativlos um einen
sprechen aus der Politik aufzugreifen
und das hinterlässt natürlich Spuren und
wenn ich das jetzt mal auf heute runter
breche habe ich das große Problem im
Moment dass ich diese Beschwörungen ja
wir müssen wieder uns auf den
krisenwinter einstimmen Corona wird ganz
schrecklich diese Alarmismus da muss ich
doch als sage mal etwas über die Grenzen
schauen der Medienkonsument einfach auch
mal gucken was passiert in der
Nachbarländern ja ich muss ja nicht in
den Urlaub fahren um festzustellen dass
alle anderen Länder in Europa und
weltweit die Sache etwas sachlicher und
pragmatischer angehen also dieser
Alarmismus den wir über Monate und Jahre
jetzt erlebt haben der hat glaube ich
auch der Glaubwürdigkeit der Medien sehr
geschadet und man müsste da auch
rhetorisch zurückfahren und wieder zu
einer gewissen Sachlichkeit zurückkehren
aber ich finde gerade jetzt wenn man
sich die Phase jetzt anguckt dann wird
viel mehr euch hinterfragt also diese
Alarmismus den sie jetzt angesprochen
haben deswegen man hat natürlich gesehen
es gab Prognosen wo viele Politiker
falsch gelegen haben da haben wir auch
als Journalisten draus gelernt es war ja
eine extreme Phase die wir alle nicht
kannten und wenn jetzt irgendwelche
Horror Prognosen für den Herbst und für
den Winter kommen dann finde ich dass
das aus der aus den Medien viel stärker
hinterfragt wenn ich bin ein
gutes Beispiel ist Lauterbach als
Gesundheitsminister als eher
Gesundheitsminister geworden ist gab es
ja auch so einen totalen medienhypes
nach dem Motto endlich wird Lauterbach
der einzige der sich wissenschaftlich
damit auskennt Gesundheitsminister und
Scholz wurde quasi dazu gedrängt
er musste ja deswegen sind da werden und
dann haben aber sehr viele Medien auch
Lauterbach kritisch hinterfragt und
meiner Meinung nach auch sehr stark
entzaubert und deswegen hat sich da
schon eine ganze Menge gearbeitet der
Ton in weiten Bereichen der Medien ist
nach wie vor schrill ja und es herrscht
ein Alarmismus den ich im Moment jetzt
wieder wahrnehme jetzt kommt der Herbst
jetzt müssen wir alle Angst haben jetzt
müssen gibt es große Probleme aber diese
diese Argumentation zieht eben
letztendlich für den sachlich
orientierten Medienkonsumenten nicht
mehr sondern der braucht eben sozusagen
Abwägung da muss ich auch ganz einfach
sagen ich habe die Tage auf Twitter
geschrieben ich bin jetzt hier fach
geimpft und ich bin kein Impfgegner aber
ich respektiere jeden der ist anders
sieht und das ist doch die Einstellung
mit der auch die Medien daran gehen
müssen dass man sagt wir informieren
euch und ihr könnt die Entscheidung
treffen übrigens ich glaube jetzt gerade
werden viele Jugendliche ihre Fans weil
es gibt eine neue Studie die besagt dass
vor allem bei den Jugendlichen der
Medien ein ganz großes
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem haben also vor
allem die Jugendlichen Vertrauen unserer
Berichterstattung eigentlich mehr jetzt
Business Zeit er spricht ja auch vor
allem die jungen Leute an aber ich habe
diese Studie heute auch gelesen ich war
echt schon echt schockiert da geht es um
über 70 Prozent der Befragten die kein
Vertrauen in die Medien haben und da
müssen wir uns natürlich auch ohne Frage
kr zu hinterfragen weil das ist
natürlich etwas ganz heftiges wenn wir
die jungen Leute nicht erreichen wir
werden ja später noch auf die
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen kommen die
erreichen die jungen Leute sowieso nicht
aber wir müssen natürlich schauen dass
wir diese jungen Leute erreichen weil da
bilden sich Meinungen und das geht nicht
nur durch instas wir machen jetzt direkt
mal mit dem zweiten großen Thema weiter
was die Presse ja aktuell beschäftigt
Corona ist ja etwas in Hintergrund
geraten und das ist die Lage der
Wirtschaft und vor allem die energielage
und da hat uns Herr boltin heute ein
Thema mitgebracht
es geht um die gasumlage und es geht
darum dass diese gasumlage letztlich
dazu führt dass extra Profite der
Konzerne noch weiter gesteigert werden
und zwar das zu Lasten der
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher und wir
wissen an alle dass durch steigende
Mieten durch explodierende
Nahrungsmittelpreise wir haben heute
gesehen Inflation steigt und gerade bei
Nahrungsmittel um 16%. das können sich
viele Familien einfach nicht mehr
leisten und eben durch steigende
Energiepreise sind die ohnehin vieler
Familien mit kleinen und mittleren
Einkommen längst am Limit und viele
Menschen sind bedroht von ihrer sozialen
Existenz und deswegen sage ich ganz klar
diese gasumlage muss weg sie schafft
soziale Ungerechtigkeit sie gefährdet
Menschen und wir sagen ganz klar wir
brauchen ein gaspreisentdeckel
beispielsweise ein Gaspreise entdecke wo
gesagt wird man schaut wie war der
Gaspreis vor dem Ukraine Krieg und dann
Deckel der Start das so und das machen
andere europäische Staaten auch machen
das erfolgreich Spanien in Portugal
beispielsweise aber sogar auch Ungarn
was glaube ich nicht im Verdacht steht
irgendwie Links zu sein
und wir brauchen das hier auch in
Deutschland wir brauchen die Entlastung
der Bürgerinnen und Bürger und wir sagen
ganz klar wir müssen jetzt die Mehrheit
entlasten und wir müssen diejenigen die
großen Konzerne die massiv profitieren
jetzt von der Krise die müssen wir
stärker belasten sie sprechen
wahrscheinlich von der übergewinnsteuer
wenn sie sagen sie wollen belastend
würde ich jetzt tippen das ist nicht
ganz falsch die übergewinnsteuer auch
das im europäischen Ausland in vielen
Staaten so Großbritannien Boris Johnson
hat's gemacht und mit Erfolg weil da
lässt sich beispielsweise sowas wie ein
gaspreisdeckel ja dann auch
sinnvollerweise gegen finanzieren weil
wir brauchen jetzt in dieser Situation
die Entlastung damit Leute eben nicht
ihre Wohnung im verlieren damit sie noch
am Ende des Monats wirklich Geld haben
um ihre grundbedarfe die wollen sie die
übergewinnsteuer in Deutschland Steuer
sich umsetzen nein einfach nur da ganz
kurz ich glaube das wesentlich ist
erstmal die Frage der Entlastung und des
Gaspreis am Deckels aber wir haben
mittlerweile unterschiedliche Gutachten
das wissenschaftlichen Dienstes des
Bundestages das erste Mal 2021 das hat
die im Bundestagsfraktion die Linke in
Auftrag gegeben weil man damals schon er
sah dass im Zuge der corona-krise eben
massive extra Gewinne angefallen haben
sind eine Frage nicht beantwortet wie
wollen Sie steuerrechtlich umsetzen wir
wollen glaube ich hier keine
steuerrechtliche Diskussion aber führen
der wissenschaftlich
der Wissenschaftliche Dienst des
Bundestages schlägt als Weg vor man
nimmt sozusagen die durchschnittlichen
Gewinne der beispielsweise letzten fünf
Jahre mittelte das und das ist wieder
nicht macht Steuerrecht denn der
Steuerrecht weil das Problem ist nämlich
was sie vorschlagen die übergewinnsteuer
die ist aktuell verfassungswidrig in
Deutschland wir haben eine andere sagt
Gutachten die uns vorliegen es sind drei
Gutachten zu übergewinnstein allen drei
Gutachten sagt der Wissenschaftliche
Dienst es ist verfassungsrechtlich
möglich und ich glaube wir sollten da
dem wissenschaftlichen Dienst des
Bundestages
Glauben schenken es ist definitiv eine
verfassungsrechtliche Kernproblem einer
übergewinnsteuer die gibt es weil die
übergewinnsteuer wäre nämlich eine
Ertragssteuer auf den Gewinn und das
über eine solche Steuer muss bei allen
Unternehmen gleich sein es gibt sogar
einen Fall wo das auch schon gescheitert
ist in den letzten Jahren am
Verfassungsgericht und dementsprechend
ist schon meine Frage wie das überhaupt
umgesetzt werden soll und zwar war es
nämlich der Versuch Gewinner einer
Branche gezielt abzuschöpfen ist vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht gescheitert im
Fall der Kernbrennstoffsteuer was die ja
bekannt sein die Frage ist also wir
können ja nicht einfach die Gesetze
ändern
das war nicht das zentrale Problem
meines Wissens und das waren Probleme
die bekannt waren die der damalige
Minister aber durchaus den Kauf
angenommen hat da gab es eine relativ
breite Debatte in den Medien
selbstverständlich kommt es darauf an
dass verfassungsfest zu machen
selbstverständlich und da kann man sich
keine Schnellschüsse erlauben und da
sollte man sich dann auch vielleicht
nicht bei den Energiekonzernen beraten
lassen wie es wahrscheinlich bei der
gasumlage
geschehen ist sondern da sollte man sich
wirklich auf Verfassungsrechtler ändern
dann konzentrieren und die mit
einbeziehen diese Berater mietdeckel
denn ihre Partei in Berlin
vorangetrieben hatte war ja schon mal
nicht verfassungsfest also und wissen
Sie warum weil weil
die Auskunft war und das haben sie ja
wahrscheinlich auch mitbekommen dass das
auf Bundesebene gesehen
aber auch damals gab es unterschiedliche
Auslegungen ich fand es richtig dass man
dass man das versucht hat und ich bin
angesichts der Situation die wir jetzt
haben ohnehin der Ansicht dass wenn
mietendeckel bräuchten auf Bundesebene
zumindest die Möglichkeit
Thema bleiben ich finde es ja erstmal
charmant die Idee ist ja charmant dass
man sagt da gibt es krisenprofiteure wie
bei jeder Krise den nimmt man das Geld
weg und die anderen bekommen ist so und
das Entscheidende ist wirklich diese
Umsetzung also ich habe Angst also ich
das ist schon echt ein massiver
markteingriff und manchmal muss und es
gibt eine neue Steuer und wir wissen ja
alle wenn es eine neue Steuer gibt dann
bleibt die sehr lange und ich habe so
ein bisschen Befürchtung dass da so ein
bürokratisches Monstrum entsteht wo ganz
viele Beamte die Bilanzen von allen
möglichen Konzernen durch Forsten und
dann sagen so
Mineralölkonzern XY du musst jetzt das
und das zahlen und dann geht er dagegen
vor vor Gericht und der Start
profitierte übrigens auch von den
Mineralöl steuern und so weiter aber ich
sehe das ähnlich ich glaube das ist ein
Riesenproblem bei der Umsetzung das
hinzubekommen also die Idee charmant
aber ich
anderen europäischen Staaten
funktioniert warum soll es nicht auch
mal in Deutschland funktionieren warum
sollte sich Deutschland
werfen es ist kein gutes Beispiel also
mit der Unternehmer Standort würde
zurückwerfen man kann die Länder auch
steuerrechtlich überhaupt nicht mehr
vergleichen aber das stimmt doch
überhaupt ganz anders aufgestellt doch
man kann Steuerrecht nicht mehr
vergleichbar mit dem Länder Standort
sondern was haben wir gerade für ein
Problem wir haben doch kein Problem das
Shell oder andere große Konzerne gerade
notleiden sind und da haben die haben
teilweise 200 bis 400% im Gewinne diese
gemacht hat sondern wir haben gerade ein
Problem das nicht nur die BürgerInnen in
Deutschland am leiden unter diesen
Energiepreisen sondern auch das
Produzieren der Gewerbe die kleinen
mittelständischen Unternehmen auch die
müssen wir belassen
und auch eine Frage stellen und zwar
brauchen wir diese Steuern also hat der
Staat ein Problem mit zu wenig
Geldeinnahmen oder vielleicht Ausgaben
also wo liegt da das von brauchen wir
jetzt diese Einnahmen um den Armen
Bürgern den Unternehmen zu helfen
braucht der Staat noch
ganz gewiss nicht jeder Staat hat
genügend Geld es ist ein ein fetter
Träger aber sehr sehr reicher Staat also
wir sein alter Kater also quasi es ist
sehr beleibt aber mehr oder minder
impotent das ist das ist unser Start
momentan und da ist noch eine neue
Steuer drauf zum Sattel will mir
prinzipiell nicht einleuchten da hier
finde ich schon interessant dass sie
sich auf den sogenannten
Rechtspopulisten Boris Johnson Berufen
ist auch interessante Allianz ist ja
fast so ein kleines Hufeisen und und zum
zweiten die Unternehmen ist sie genannt
haben ich bin kein Steuerexperte aber
die Unternehmen die sie genannt haben
Shell und BP glaube ich sind wirklich
mal deutsch Unternehmen also wie will
man dies drauf verpflichten dass die
eine deutsche Steuerung
schnell das ist irgendwie so schnell
dass es wirkt also
wie gesagt wir haben die Beispiele wir
haben die Staaten in denen es
funktioniert wir haben die Studien wir
wissen dass wir bis zu 100 Milliarden
jährlich einnehmen können und da will
ich Ihnen was sagen es geht nicht um den
Staatshaushalt sondern es geht wirklich
darum mit diesem Geldern die kleine und
mittleren Einkommen zu entlassen die
Menschen die immer gewinnen sie haben
gerade gesagt es geht nicht um den
Haushalt ja aber wenn wir genug Geld
haben wozu brauchen wir denn eine neue
Steuer dann können wir die Menschen doch
auch so entlasten das sind das sind
extra Profite die dieser Unternehmen
machen und die müssen umverteilt werden
wir haben Problem in Deutschland das
momentan sowohl in der corona-krise als
auch in dieser Energiekrise die kleinen
und mittleren unter Quatsch Einkommen
massiver Verluste gehabt haben da gab es
gerade eine Studie minus vier Prozent
gerade durch die Inflation trotz
steigender Löhne das heißt das ist ein
massives am Problem und wenn ich weiß
nicht ob sie das schon bekommen haben
wir haben das bekommen von unserem Gas
Anbieter der schreibt uns
herbertin das mag für sie verrückt
klingen und wir wissen dass es für Sie
absolut unvorstellbar ist aber wir
werden zum Ende des Jahres mindesten
unseren Preis verdreifachen müssen das
heißt wir werden unsere Rechnung von
1700 auf
5000 Euro oder so gesteigert am bekommen
und weitere Steigerungen im nächsten
Jahr schließen wir nicht ab
finden Sie das gibt ihnen das Recht zu
entscheiden was gute und was böse
Gewinne sind das ist ja auch was vom
Moral zu sagen okay das Unternehmen
zu tun und Unternehmen haben auch in
diesem Fall nichts mit moralarm nicht
entscheiden was ein guter Gewinn ist und
was ein schlechter geworden
wir haben da Kriegs Profiteur Profite
ja wenn Sie das so wollen sind es keine
super tollen Gewinne wo man sagen kann
hey cool was machst du sondern wir
wollen an dieser Stelle tatsächlich mehr
Gerechtigkeit am schaffen und das ist
extrem
notwendig an dieser Stelle bahntec hat
eine Innovation gemacht Geschäfts wissen
Sie ja auch weiterhin mRNA
man kann an dieser Stelle darüber im
diskutieren in meiner vernünftige im
Besteuerung wir reden aber hier an
dieser Stelle wirklich um diese
Energiekrise wir reden um die Entlastung
von kleinen und mittleren am Einkommen
wir reden auch über unsere Demokratie
weil wenn es so ist dass 60% der
Haushalte damit jetzt massive Probleme
bekommen werden
also das haben sie noch nicht erklärt
warum es die jetzt braucht um die zu
entlasten Sie vermischen hier zwei
Themen wenn wir die Schuldenbremse
wegnehmen würden dann
gebe ich in einem recht ich halte die
Schuldenbremse nicht für rechtlich hat
sie für eine Investition zusammenbremse
müssen wir wegnehmen also in dieser
Logik selbstverständlich wäre ich
vollkommen Wein würde ich sofort mit
ihnen machen leider werden wir
wahrscheinlich wir beide das nicht
entscheidend können und uns einfach
nicht auf was einigen können wer
vielleicht sogar wahrscheinlich weil die
Einigung schwer schwierig
ich habe sie leider unterbrochen bitte
sagen wenn ich das mal als Verbraucher
ansprechen darf wir reden jetzt darüber
wo Milliarden die irgendwo abgeschöpft
worden sind wieder in den Staatshaushalt
zurückgeführt werden können und was man
Gutes damit machen kann im Sinne eine
Entlastung die Katze dreht sich im Kreis
und beißt sich immer wieder in den
Schwanz denn die Grundproblematik müsste
aus meiner Sicht angegangen werden
nämlich die man muss die Erkenntnisse
haben die Milliarden sind nicht das
Problem sondern die Kilowattstunden die
in den Stromnetzen fehlen ja das heißt
wenn man schon gezielt nicht man darf
nicht nur steuerlich gezielt entlasten
im Sinne ihr müsst ihr werdet jetzt habt
ihr mehr Geld im Geldbeutel dann muss
sagen wo kommt denn jetzt der Strom her
und deswegen würde deswegen würde ich
die Frage stellen wo ist denn hier wenn
wir auf ein krisenwinter zugehen auch
das entschlossene Krisenmanagement das
sagt lasst uns mal bitte klar benennen
was das Problem ist nämlich nicht 300
Euro mehr im Monat im Jahr oder für ein
Haushalt oder was auch immer ein
geringer größerer Betrag sondern dass
der Strom beschafft wird das empfinde
ich als Verbraucher als große Frechheit
im Moment dass hier akademisch über
übergewinnsteuer gasumlagen diskutiert
wird aber man offensichtlich in der
Debatte aus meiner Sicht momentan
vergisst dass das Grundproblem ein
möglicher Strom oder gasmangel als
solcher ist ja und da fehlt mir
persönlich als Bürger das
Krisenmanagement ja das hatte ich an
dieser Stelle für überheblich zu sagen
das ist nicht das Problem weil wenn sie
mal mit Leuten die wirklich jetzt am
Rande ihre Existenz sind sehr sehr
Konkretes
natürlich ist es ein Problem aber
selbstverständlich haben Sie vollkommen
Recht momentan haben wir mit der Strom
am Produktion auch im Zuge des
Klimawandels ein Problem wir leben ein
großer Strommengen am gerade nach
Frankreich weil wir wissen die
Atomkraftwerke sind dort am Rott die
funktionieren teilweise auch im Zuge des
Klimawandels Stichwort
nicht das ist ein massives Problem aber
es europäische Solidarität im die da
eingefordert ist aber auch Frankreich
hatten preisdeckel auf Frankreich
ermöglicht den Menschen da über die
Runden zu kommen und wir müssen jetzt
ermöglichen den Menschen über die Runden
zu kommen Sie für die Verlängerung der
Atomkraftwerke ich halte die
Verlängerung der Atomkraftwerke für eine
falsche Option weil wir wissen das würde
etwa ein Prozent des Gasbedarfs ein
ersparen dafür gibt es andere Wege dort
dann gibt es Einsparungen bei der
Industrie auch Einsparung bei
Privathaushalten durch vernünftige
Ansätze wodurch man das gut kompensieren
kann und ich halte das für fahrlässig
jetzt zu sagen wir verlängern in dieser
Stelle die Laufzeiten es gibt dafür vier
aber wenn wir doch sagen wir gehen auf
einen energienotstand zu der im Winter
praktisch für jeden Bürger gerade für
den Bürger mit schmalen Geldbeutel
spürbar wird indem die Wohnung nicht
mehr heiß wird indem er vielleicht
morgens nicht mehr duschen kann
dann fehlt mir jedes Verständnis dafür
dass man da nicht sagt wir müssen dieses
Problem konkret angehen durch Handlungen
und nicht durch finanzielle
Umverteilungen da haben sie völlig
finanzielle Umverteilung ist ein gutes
Stichwort für Herrn Kissler gegebener
Stichwort muss ich hier gar nicht mehr
selber moderieren und zwar hat der
Kistler auch etwas mitgebracht was auch
im weitesten Sinne nicht so Umverteilung
passt ja unser Bundesfinanzminister
Christian Lindner ein Nebenberuf
Vorsitzender der FDP hat sich ja ein
handelsüblichen Shitstorm eingehandelt
als er von der Gratismentalität sprach
und mit dieser Gratismentalität das 9
euro-ticket in die ewigen Jagdgründe
verweisen wollte aber so Leute Pistole
hatte damit recht es ist ja sogar noch
schlimmer wir haben eine Vollkasko
Mentalität in Deutschland meine ich wann
immer etwas mit Links soll der Staat zur
Seite stehen und der Staat macht das
sehr gerne weil der Staat hat lieber
abhängige Untertan als freie Bürger das
ist das Problem wir haben mit die
höchste Steuer- und Abgabenquote in der
ganzen Welt ich glaube nur Belgien ist
in Europa noch vor uns der Staat wird
immer fetter immer träger immer
inaktiver und ab und zu verteilt er dann
kleine pflasterchen gut zwischen Bonbons
damit der Untertan nicht allzu
widerspenstig wird statt einem Staat der
immer wieder die Klientel befüttert die
am lautesten im Moment gerade schreit
ist also einen Staat der immer nur
scheinbar gibt gibt bräuchten wir ein
Staat der viel viel weniger nimmt wenn
wir nämlich eine geringere Abgabenquote
hätte geringere Steuern für alle
geringere Mehrwertsteuer auf
obstgetreide und Gemüse ein höheren
steuerbauschbetrag und für das Alter
vorsorgen zu können etc pp dann wären
wir alle wieder freie Bürger wir könnten
mehr Verantwortung übernehmen wir
könnten mehr für unser Alter für unsere
nächsten für unsere lieben vorsorgen und
wir wären weniger in dieser Abhängigkeit
allerdings der Staat schützt diese
Vollkasko Mentalität weil er eben gerne
die Gouvernante ist die am Bette steht
und jedem deutschen Michel die
nachtkappe ins Gesicht zieht er ist ganz
haben wir ein Problem mit dem deutschen
mindset also ich finde es ich finde es
wunderbar wie das eben vor klar geworden
ist und ich finde auch gerade diese das
kam jetzt ja los auch durch den neuen
euro-ticket und den Tank Rabatt also es
sind ja wirklich so Goodies die
hingeworfen wo man das Gefühl hat okay
wir müssen jetzt mal was rüberbringen
Entlastung wir reden momentan über alle
möglichen Entlastungen die Parteien
überbieten sich wir haben die
Wahnsinnigen Ausgaben für die Bundeswehr
durch den Ukraine Krieg wir haben
riesige Ausgaben für Corona also wir
haben doch mal darüber gesprochen dass
wir in Deutschland so eine schwarze Null
haben wollten ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
noch gar nicht erinnert also das ist ja
noch gar nicht so lange her und jetzt
kann Schäuble jetzt hat man das Gefühl
es ist für alle alles da also das finde
ich schon sehr problematisch und es dann
entsteht natürlich das Gefühl dass jede
klientelgruppe sagt okay dann holen wir
uns das als nächstes
Abhängigkeiten das finde ich einfach so
schlimm wir sind hier eine Republik
sondern wir sind eine Gruppe mehr oder
weniger unverbundener
Opfergruppen an berechtigter und jeder
bekommt ab und zu mal sein kleines
lüsschen gestellt und dann gehen wir
wieder unsere Wege sind still und
schreien halt wieder den Schnabel auf
und dann kommt der starten füttert und
früher hat man doch immer gesagt wir
müssen auch an die nächsten Generationen
denken ja die nächsten Generationen die
diesen Schuldenberg irgendwann abtragen
müssen ich habe das in letzter Zeit
nicht mehr gehört hier geht's immer nur
darum das aufzubauen und aufzubauen ich
finde es sehr sehr problematische
Entwicklung
sauer das ist eigentlich immer nur noch
darum geht zu verschenken anstatt auch
mal zu sparen habe großes Sympathie für
das was der DR Kistler gesagt hat er
bringt das auf den Punkt was natürlich
gerade auch Selbstständige oder Leute im
Führungspositionen oder ähnliches bewegt
dass eben die Arbeit sich teilweise dann
tatsächlich nicht mehr lohnt das ist
natürlich schon spürbar aber ich will
einen ganz wichtigen Punkt sagen auch
auf die gefallen dass ich mich unbeliebt
mache ich glaube sie hätten diese dieses
narrativ nicht gerade am 9 euro-ticket
festmachen sollen denn das 9 Ticket
empfinde ich als Steuerzahlen der Bürger
als einen ganz wesentlichen Schritt in
die Richtung dass der Bürger zum
Beispiel versteht was mit einer
möglicherweise durch Klimaveränderungen
mobilitätswende möglich ist ja ich
hundert Prozent sind umgeschrieben ich
will ich will nicht es ist einfach ein
psychologischer Effekt aus aus meinem
Lebensumfeld den ich festgestellt habe 9
Euro für immer müssen es neun Euro sein
können es nicht auch 39 sein
ich kenne ja jetzt nicht ihr Gehalt das
muss ich auch gar nicht kennen aber ich
kann zum Beispiel bei mir sagen
für mich muss der Staat keinen neun Euro
Ticket zahlen also ich brauche es nicht
jetzt ist die Frage ob sie das brauchen
diesen Zuschuss ich glaube halt einfach
muss man dieses gießkanntprinzip machen
das sollte man nicht vielleicht lieber
dass er ja wie sagt man das durch einen
Schlauch auf die Menschen wo es wirklich
ankommen muss
sprechen aber das ist doch genau der
Punkt nur da sage ich gerade das 9
euro-ticket hat aus meiner Sicht
psychologisch gesehen für mich als
Bürger als Verbraucher einen eine
Signalwirkung gehabt ja hier hat sich
doch mal zumindest spürbar etwas bewegt
in der Politik gekauft von solchen
Situationen
wie groß war denn die Wirkung des 9 Euro
Tickets also das jetzt alle auf das auf
die Bahn umgestiegen sind das waren ja
wirklich überschaubar und wann
überschaubare zahlen und ich glaube
gerade dieses Gießkannenprinzip das ist
ein entscheidender Punkt meine Tochter
arbeitet nach ihrer Ausbildung in einer
Arztpraxis hat einen sagen wir mal
überschaubares Gehalt und für die war
dieses 9 € Ticket super logisch ich
brauche nicht ich brauche dieses 9 €
Ticket nicht genauso wie jetzt wo über
das energiegeld geredet wird und das ist
doch das Hauptproblem das wirklich mit
diesem
Gießkannenprinzip die Gelder diese
Milliarden Summen die wir ja alle zu
steuern das ist ja nicht das fällt ja
nicht vom Himmel dass die gegeben werden
und da muss man doch viel
zielgerichteter Vorgehen wirklich für
die Leute die bedürftig sind also wenn
sie es nicht gebraucht haben da hätten
sie es ja auch nicht kaufen haben
brauchen aber ich will jetzt erstmal zum
ich bin jetzt erstmal zum Thema TM
zurück zur Frage der Gratismentalität
ich halte das für ein sehr verheerenden
Begriffe und ich kann Ihnen das auch
erstmal erklären zum einen haben sie
etwas vollkommen durcheinander gebracht
vielleicht an dieser Stelle und zwar
haben sie davon gesprochen wir hätten
hier die höchste Steuern Abgabenquote
das ist so nicht richtig sondern sondern
wir haben hier die Situation das kleine
und mittlere Einkommen tatsächlich am
stärksten besteuert werden was ein
großes Problem
aber das ist nicht ganz richtig weil
Vermögen und hohe Einkommen mit am
geringsten
in der Europäischen Union da gab es
heute auch noch mal eine Studie das hat
die oecdm auch bestätigt das heißt wir
haben massives Ungleichgewicht am an
dieser Stelle aber wir haben sehr wenig
privat aber
hat das gesagt nachdem er dann
zu seiner Hotline einen falschen Fakt
vorgeworfen es ist kein falscher Faktor
Vergleich miteinander
andere Sachen nur gerade verglichen das
stimmt ähm nicht ganz an dieser Stelle
sondern man muss schon gucken wo das
heißt wenn man er sagt allgemein ist es
zu hoch stimmt's einfach nicht weil für
hohe Einkommen und für hohe Vermögen
sind die Steuern in Deutschland halt
einfach nicht so weit sondern
richtig und höhere Sätze beim
barfußschale der gratis Mentalität an
dieser Stelle denn an dem Tag danach war
es glaube ich ist Lindner dann abgedüst
nach Sylt zu seiner Hochzeit hat dafür
auch öffentliche Gelder in Anspruch
genommen was die Sicherheitsdienste
beispielsweise angeht das ist eine
gratis Mentalität oder recherchieren Sie
das richtig herbertin okay dann dann tut
mir das leid aber auf unsere Frage
Frage hin er konnte der deutsche
Bundestag da keine Antwort darauf geben
wir haben das nachgefragt müsste man
recherchieren wer vielleicht ganz am
spannend an dieser Stelle aber reden wir
beispielsweise über fossile Subventionen
65 Milliarden Euro jährlich gehen in
fossile Subventionen gratis sozusagen
und das schadet den Klima das kostet den
deutschen am Startgeld beim 9
euro-ticket haben wir aber eine andere
Situation wir wissen mittlerweile zehn
Prozent der Fahrten die sonst mit dem
Auto gemacht worden sind sind mit der
Bahn gemacht worden das ist gestern
gerade am rausgekommen vom Band der
Deutschen
verkehrssünderunternehmen ist das
gestern rausgekommen das ist relativ gut
in einem sogenannten Autofahrer im Land
das eine gute Zahl das der zweite fakt
ist es ist auch CO2 eingespart worden
und zwar in drei Monaten so viel CO2 wie
beispielsweise ein Tempolimit von 130 in
einem hergebracht hätte auch das
entlastet das staatssekel das etwas
dadurch entlastet mit diesem neuen
m-euro-ticket also ich glaube ich glaube
weiß nicht ob die Zahl stimmt kann aber
sein drei oder zwei oder zehn Prozent
ich bin ja auch Frau ja auch oft Bahn
und ich kann nur sagen wer zum ersten
Mal Bahn gefahren ist eines drei oder
zehn Prozent im Rahmen der 9 Euro super
duper los wachos Wochen der fährt
vielleicht danach nicht mehr baden weil
es knalle voll war weil es gestunken hat
wie Hulle aus den Toiletten heraus weil
man gewartet hat auf engen Bahnsteigen
hier in Berlin Hauptbahnhof ich war vor
dass dann jeden Tag einer tot ausgezogen
wird also diese dreimal neun los wachos
locker Wochen aber man könnte ja eine
Werbung dann könnt ihr sagen dass besser
werden
danach sind wir auch schon wieder für
Sie da bis gleich
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfe fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatchat Uschi der Wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit diese
grün-roten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die
rettungsweltklimas und um die Füße
rumwuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel
zu wichtig um es nur der AFD zu
überlassen lass den Leuten noch mal den
Spaß wir sehen da etwas was eigentlich
fatal ist in der Politik bei den
Journalisten deren Job ist es doch
gerade abweichende Meinungen zu finden
und sie sollen den doch auch richtig
doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto das wäre ganz nett das sind
irgendwelche anorakträger aus Buxtehude
die das Gucken so ich habe mein Beifall
in meiner lache immer bekommen wer
kümmert sich darum niemand dittis ja man
muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch darüber
sprechen dass es einfach nicht fährt und
nicht richtig durch die Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir haben die kurze Unterbrechung
natürlich für einen schnellen
Faktencheck genutzt und Deutschland ist
Vize Steuer Weltmeister auf jeden Fall
nach der OECD Studie und nach Berichten
wie beispielsweise im Handelsblatt und
damit geben wir jetzt weiter zu Ihnen
und Ihrem Thema zum
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ja sehr
gerne also es geht um luxuriöse
Dienstwagen mit massagesitzen es geht um
teure Beraterverträge und heimliche Boni
und das alles auf Kosten der
Steuerzahler nicht der Steuerzahler
sondern der gebührenzahl wir waren
gerade bei den Steuern
die rbb-affäre um Patricia Schlesinger
die ja empört die Republik und die
erschüttert die ARD es ist wohl die
größte der größte Skandal in der langen
Geschichte des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks ist es so lange nicht zu Ende
denn es gibt immer weitere Enthüllungen
um verschiedene ARD-Sender jetzt jüngst
beim NDR da geht es darum dass
Redakteure schwere Vorwürfe gegen die
Sendeleitung erhoben haben es wird krit
Berichterstattung teils unterdrückt von
politischen Filter ist die Rede und ja
wir können nur sagen Tatort ARD es ist
dringend Zeit für echtere Formen im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk welche
Maßnahmen schlagen Sie ganz konkret vor
also es geht vor allen Dingen um erstens
um die Kontrolle was ich erschreckend
finde gerade bei in diesem rbb Fall war
da gibt es Gremien wie den
Verwaltungsrat und den Rundfunkrat da
sitzen viele Leute drin die eigentlich
diese ganzen Gelder kontrollieren sollen
aber das sind teilweise Amateure die
waren ja auch überfordert und sind
mittlerweile auch zurückgetreten dann
ganz wichtig Transparenz ich habe als
Gebührenzahler ein Recht darauf nicht
zur nicht nur zu erfahren was der
Intendant einer ARD-Anstalt verdient
soll was kosten eigentlich diese ganzen
Sendungen dort was kostet eine Florian
Silbereisen Show am Samstagabend oder
ein hirschhausen-quiz was man das nicht
das ist nicht offiziell bekannt gegeben
worden bisher es wird ein riesen
Geheimnis zum Beispiel gemacht um die
Pension die Altersvorsorge im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk ist ja
sehr sehr üppig wir haben jetzt
recherchiert dass zum Beispiel die RBB
Direktorin die jetzt dort diesen ganzen
Schlamassel zu verantworten haben dass
die teilweise bis zu
13.014.000 Euro im Monat bekommen ihre
Medium den Fall Schlesinger aufgedeckt
ja und das war ja schon ein riesiger
Fall auch herzlichen Glückwunsch am
Business Insider immer gut wenn ihr
Presse kontrolliert aber war das nur die
Spitze des Eisberges ja das interessante
war ja dass dann sich ARD Intendanten
hingestellt haben und sagen oh Gott
schlimm was da beim rbb entstanden ist
und da müssen wir das Vertrauen
entziehen das ist natürlich alles ein
Einzelfall ich kann mich auch gut daran
erinnern als erst wenige Tage her da hat
sich die Intendanten des Bayerischen
Rundfunks in einem Interview hingestellt
und sagt alles Singular beim ähm beim
rbb ist das gibt's nirgendwo anders und
wir bekommen jetzt wirklich sehr sehr
viele Hinweise aus anderen ARD Anstalten
gehen den natürlich nach und wir sind ja
jetzt schon beim NDR darauf gestoßen
dass es dort Einflussnahme auf die
berichter Bewertung gibt ich weiß gar
nicht was schlimmer ist ob es die
gebührenverschwendung ist oder ob
sozusagen die eigentliche Staatsferne
missbraucht wird wie läuft die
Einflussnahme ab wird da angerufen
seitens der Politik beim NDR oder wissen
Sie da schon mehr da ging es um
Berichterstattung zum
CDU Ministerpräsidenten Daniel Günther
der hatte einen Konflikt mit seinem
Innenminister und dann wurde die
Berichterstattung so gemacht dass der
Daniel Günther eigentlich den sie auch
alle Daniel nennen im NDR
rundfunkhaus dort in Kiel wurde die eher
so in Richtung Daniel Günther getreten
da wurden wirklich kritische Passagen
und das finde ich wirklich erschreckend
kritische Passagen wurden
rausgeschnitten und es und dann wurde
das auch diskutiert intern immerhin es
wurde diskutiert und dann gab es massive
Vorwürfe da wurde gesprochen von einem
politischen Filter und dass die CDU
Landesregierung von diesem
Landesfunkhaus geschützt werden sollte
jetzt ist ja letzte Woche wieder auch
wieder jemand zurückgetreten dem MDR die
landesfunkhauschefin in Sachsen-Anhalt
weil ihr ist plötzlich eingefallen dass
sie Ehemann in eine Betrugsaffäre vor
einigen Jahren verwickelt worden ist und
also ich habe das Gefühl jetzt dass wir
da wirklich richtig in ein Wespennest
reingesteckt haben ja die Situation auch
dass es gibt ja Themen die auch wirklich
dem renommeeschaden des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks nehmen
Sie den Flug im regierungsflieger nach
Kanada ja da ist ja in den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Medien das
narrativ kritiklos verbreitet worden da
war juristisch alles in Ordnung ich
spreche jetzt mal als Jurist ja ich weiß
dass mittlerweile der Versuch gemacht
worden ist namhafte
luftverkehrsexperten dafür zu gewinnen
zu sagen ja das war alles richtig
bislang hat sich nur noch keiner
gefunden nur die Berichterstattung die
über Tage so gewesen ist ich wir wissen
gar nicht worüber ich und ihr euch
aufgeht geht wieder maskenpflicht ja die
gilt sowieso wieder das ist ja nicht das
Thema aber es wird ja behauptet im
regierungsflieger war alles in Ordnung
das ist juristisch aber falsch aber in
der ARD gerade im ZDF konnten sie
tagelang einfach das narrativführen ist
alles juristisch in Ordnung die dürfen
das also ich glaube und das ist einfach
falsch ich glaube dass wir deswegen auch
auf der auf dem richtigen Weg sind da
den Finger in die Wunde zu legen weil
wir bekommen sehr viel Zuspruch auch von
den Mitarbeitern im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk weil die
sagen natürlich ist total wichtig dass
diese ganzen Geschichten mal ans
Tageslicht bekommen weil da gibt es ja
wirklich sehr sehr viel junge Kunden
Geld also ist ja nicht dass jeder dort
Reich sich reich schöpft und gerade beim
rbb gab es ja die Diskussion dass da
sehr viel gespart wird dass man überlegt
wird kommen die freien überhaupt zum
Zuge was bekommen sie und so weiter
werden sie gebucht und dann bekommen sie
auf der anderen Seite mit das ja die
chefintage man muss es wirklich sagen in
Saus und Braus lebt es ist aber nicht
nur das Thema wenn ich das kurz sagen
darf der Frage der der politischen
Kontrolle oder ähnliches ist auch eine
Frage des völlig überbordenden gewissen
Begriffs des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks ja da sind 9 Milliarden werden
im Jahr ausgegeben nach meiner Kenntnis
für etwas was ursprünglich
verfassungsrechtlich als Grundversorgung
gedacht war ein nachrichtenprogramm ein
Fernsehballett und einen Thomas
Gottschalk über die Generationen
25 in 25-facher Ausfertigung das heißt
also dieser Apparat der da gewachsen ist
auch mit Billigung zum Beispiel des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts der ist im
Prinzip überhaupt nicht mehr mit dem
Grundgedanken der seinerzeit zur
Gründung des öffentlich-rechtlichen
Rundfunks geführt hat vereinbart das
Grundproblem ist aus meiner Sicht da
kommen wir einfach nicht drumherum ist
der Pflichtbeitrag dass jeder zahlen
muss und sonst unter Umständen sogar ins
Gefängnis wandert wenn es nicht tut egal
ob er es schaut oder nicht dass wir also
höchstrichterlich bestätigt ja gerade so
gefordert haben dass jeder zahlen muss
deutscher Staatsbürger ist viele Vereine
müssen zahlen unternehmen müssen zahlen
horrente Summen teilweise ich finde es
wäre nur nötig eine Rad Alkohol da
müssten allerdings bundesfassungsgericht
und alle Länder mitspielen das werden
sie nicht aber wenn es eine radikal
vergeben würde werden meine vier
Vorschläge erstens das ZDF abschaffen
das ist eine totale Doppelstruktur
braucht kein Mensch also nur noch ARD
ARD wiederum die drei Mini Sender Radio
Bremen sah den Rundfunk rbb abschaffen
haben wir noch sechs statt neun können
wir den umliegenden Dritter Vorschlag
Beitrag halbieren das reicht nämlich
dann auch Angebot ist auch nur halb so
groß und filtervorschlag Pflichtbeitrag
auf freiwilligen Beitrag umstellen sich
auf dem freien Markt bewerben das ist
dann wirklich gut dann kann man sagen
überzeugen durch Exzellenz und nicht
durch moralisches besser tun
nein anbieten anbieten ein gutes Angebot
machen und warum soll ich ein gutes
Angebot nicht nutzen ich bin dafür für
die öffentlich-rechtlich ich bin nicht
dafür sie abzuschaffen ist klar zu sagen
aber bitte radikal reduzieren auf den
Kern das auch redet er dort ist stolz
sein kann ja ich sollte auf Amazon Prime
zur Zeit natürlich würde ich dafür für
gute Krimis Zahlen für gute Unterhaltung
für regionale Berichterstattung die wir
sonst keine Brinker der hat ja auch der
bei der regionalen Berichterstattung
aber es gibt ja auch eine Diskussion
mittlerweile um das Programm also dass
man wirklich sagt okay da wird sind ja
über 8 Milliarden die dort zur Verfügung
stehen plus Werbung und so weiter dann
muss man sich natürlich überlegen wo
fließt das überhaupt hin und wenn ein
Großteil zum oder nicht ein Großteil
aber ein sagen wir mal zweistelliger
Bereich in die Altersversorgung geht
dann haben wir da einfach ein massives
Problem also er muss einfach gelten
Programm first warum ist das denn so
dass viele jetzt Amazon Prime oder
Netflix machen weil sie natürlich mit
dem Angebot was von ARD und ZDF kommen
nicht zufrieden sind da laufen dann
irgendwelche
Bozen Krimis und
Istanbul Krimis und so weiter ist ja
alles schön und gut die wollen ja auch
ihre Quote haben ist ja in Ordnung aber
was ich mir wünsche sind tolle
Dokumentationen Hintergrundbericht
erstatte das Programm durchgehen will
ich einmal hören weil dann wird die
Sendung hier niemals enden warum ist sie
wollen ja mit der Linken vor allem
Menschen entlasten in Deutschland das
nehme ich auch ihren parte haben Herr
warum sind sie so still was den
Rundfunkbeitrag betrifft wer das nicht
eine Entlastung für jeden Haushalt zu
sagen ja vielleicht den Vorschlag von
Herr Kessler also erstmal will ich kurz
sagen es ist vollkommen richtig wir
brauchen da Reform wir haben Strukturen
die seit langem Jahren sozusagen am
bestehen und Strukturen neigen zur
Trägheit das heißt Lücken werden
ausgenutzt das heißt wir brauchen da auf
jeden Fall die Reform das heißt wir
brauchen auch mehr Mitsprache der
mitarbeiter:innen der im Freien bin ich
von überzeugt und vor allem vor allem
die Politik sollte sich ein Stück weit
am rausziehen ich halte allerdings den
Rundfunkbeitrag für absolut notwendig
und richtig im Sinne des Auftrags des
öffentlich rechtlichen Rundfunks das
ursprünglich in einem Auftrags der
Grundversorgung ist jetzt bestätigt in
dieser Höhe ich finde es richtig ich
finde aber auch eine Diskussion über die
Frage Qualität statt Quote finde ich
richtig weil in diesem Grundauftrag
gehört eben
dass man auch die Seite der Recherche
der der Dokumentation
Nachrichtensendung beispielsweise aber
lassen Sie mir noch eine Sache
ergänzende an dieser Stelle auch bei den
privaten Sendern ist es ja durchaus so
dass jede Bürgerin jeder Bürger da mit
bezahlt nämlich über die
werbungsbeiträge die einkalkuliert sind
in die Produkte das heißt wenn ihr an
sie an die supermarkttheke gehen Produkt
am kaufen was beworben haben wird ob im
Supermarkt oder bezahlt
nein nein nein nicht direkt aber eine
sehr sehr um die Ecke
nein nein nein
jeder muss einkaufen gehen jeder das ist
ja aber belegt in allen Budgets alle
Unternehmen die sich über Werbung
sozusagen publiziert ist ein Werbebudget
eingeplant damit aber ARD und damit
machen die auch Werbung ja ihr müsst man
auch
oder nicht an dieser Stelle aber
durchaus finanzieren sich im
Privatsender auch im über die allgemeine
egal ob ich Privatsender schaue oder
nicht
theoretisch
zu vergleichen mit den privaten Sendern
naja ich gehe jetzt mal weiter
selbstbestimmungsgesetz
ja vielen Dank mein Thema ist das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz das gerade im
Bundestag forciert wird von der
Bundesregierung es geht im Wesentlichen
darum dass die Begriffe von Mann und
Frau die Geschlechter die wir kennen
aufgehoben werden sollen ganz klar
aufgehoben sie sollen künftig nicht mehr
existent sein das heißt jeder kann sich
künftig per Erklärung beim Standesamt
das wird ungefähr 20 Euro kosten die
neuer Personalausweis zu Mann oder zu
Frau machen das bedeutet ich kann mich
dann per Erklärungen zur Frau erklären
Frau Schink kann sagen auch ich möchte
gerne mal ein Mann sein oder divers und
das Schöne an der ganzen Sache ist dass
es dann nach kurzer Zeit nämlich nach
einem Jahr wieder möglich ist zu
wechseln wenn es Ihnen nicht gefällt
ändern sie wieder ihr Geschlecht
natürlich muss man sagen es gibt einen
Notwendigkeit in transsexuellen Menschen
und nonbinären Menschen zu helfen
allerdings darf man natürlich nicht
übersehen dass die nur ein Prozent nicht
nur dass die ein Prozent der Bevölkerung
ausmachen dieses Gesetz
führt jetzt dazu dass 99 Prozent der
Bürger die mit ihrer Geschlechterrolle
keinen nennenswerten Probleme haben auch
das Recht bekommen ihr Geschlecht
komplett einfach per Erklärung zu Ändern
von heute auf morgen und das zum
Beispiel Eltern das Recht bekommen für
einen Neugeborenen zu bestimmen dass der
Jonas der einen Penis hat und die Sophie
die eine Vagina hat künftig die
rollentauschen und der Junge ein Mädchen
ist und das Mädchen ein Junge das ist
der Plan des Gesetzgebers der Schutz der
transsexuellen und nonbinären Menschen
ist völlig richtig und wichtig das ist
überhaupt steht außer Frage das ist ja
auch vom Bundesverfassungsgericht zu
vorgegeben allerdings ist es so dass
natürlich hier die Frage stellt was ist
denn mit den anderen 99 Prozent was
machen denn die mit diesem Gesetz und
mit hier eröffnen sich aus meiner
Bewertung wenn jeder praktisch machen
kann was er will mit dem Geschlecht
Missbrauchsmöglichkeiten ich rede jetzt
also nicht von den unmittelbar
Betroffenen den ein Prozent die wirklich
einen Leidensdruck haben sondern von den
99 Prozent die das Gesetz nutzen können
und ich nenne diese Leute das nutzen
werden Trittbrettfahrer das sind die
Trittbrettfahrer die künftig sagen oh es
kostet ja nicht sein Geschlecht zu
ändern dann mache ich das mal die
Spaßvögel sind vielleicht die harmlosen
was ist aber mit denen Spaßvögeln die
dann tatsächlich meinen sie können zum
Beispiel in Ruhe Schutzräume für Frauen
eintreten im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes
und dort sich zeigen das ist dann nach
dem Gesetz völlig möglich Schutzräume
sind ein Beispiel Frauenquoten sind mit
dem neuen
Beispiele beispielsweise für die
Schutzräume auf amerikanischen
Gefängnissen sind ja auch schon wirklich
gefährliche Dinge passiert ich würde
gerne einmal damit nicht wir fünf die
alle glaube ich betroffen sind darüber
reden einmal von saabet blank die wir
letzte Woche hier bei Film nach acht zu
Gast ein ganz kurzen Ausschnitt zeigen
also ihr Lösungsvorschlag wäre es später
zu machen erst mit 18 vielleicht oder
was ihr Vorschlag also auf jeden Fall
erst mit 18 das auf jeden Fall und das
ist halt nicht zu verfrühten Operationen
und so weiterkommt also ich hatte zum
Beispiel im Krankenhaus nebenbett einen
18-jährigen der hat direkt Mastektomie
Hysterektomie und overectomie
zusammengemacht also noch die
Gebärmutter und Eierstockentfernung bei
dem seine Arzt ihm gesagt hat dass er
sonst Krebs bekommen würde und es war
halt keine weitere irgendwie Erklärungen
halt darüber also klar bewusst dass er
dann keine Kinder kriegen kann aber
Krebs ist halt irgendwie deine Gefahr
womöglich in zehn Jahren aber es ist ja
nicht glauben die Politik befördert das
mit dem selbstbestimmungsgesetz auf
jeden Fall ja Frau Sabel blank immer
noch er schockieren das anzusehen hat
nämlich sich die Brüste abnehmen lassen
und Hormone genommen und bereue das
jetzt und tritt sehr mutig wie ich finde
jetzt auch auf um darüber aufzuklären
wie groß ist denn die Gefahr dass durch
das selbstbestimmungsgesetz mehr dieser
Fälle auftreten wo es Menschen später
auch bereuen das ist ganz aus meiner
Sicht eindeutig der Fall durch diese
weitgehenden Möglichkeiten die jetzt
auch Eltern eingeräumt werden ich kann
es ernsthaft nicht nachvollziehen wenn
man davon ausgeht dass die unabhängige
Entwicklung eines Kindes ja ein gut als
solches ist dass zum Beispiel Eltern
dann ab dem ersten Lebensmonat das Recht
gegeben wird zu sagen oh unser Kind hat
eine rosa Rassel an am Bett fixiert also
muss es ein Mädchen sein obwohl ein
Junge ist das heißt also hier wird die
ungestörte sexuelle Entwicklung auch von
Kindern extrem gefährdet indem man eben
hier so ein weitgehenden Spielraum gibt
ohne dass man überhaupt dann noch danach
fragt gibt es hier überhaupt sozusagen
einen klinischen Grund ja also ein
Leidensdruck den wie gesagt lediglich
ein Prozent der Betroffenen überhaupt
verspürt der der Bürger verspüren aber
wie eine Frage wie hoch schätzen Sie die
Gefahr ein ich kann da jetzt schlecht
bezahlen operieren das ist jetzt ja
wirklich eine Spekulation vielleicht ist
es auch sind auch viel weniger
vielleicht der ist ja geringer das weiß
ich nicht aber ein entscheidender Punkt
ist er hier in dem Einspieler gemacht
worden ist warten dass man offenbar
schon und da verstehe ich die FDP
überhaupt nicht das ist also Liberalität
für durchgeknallte dass man als
14-Jährige oder ab 14 Jahren das schon
machen sollen darf also man ist noch gar
nicht entwickelt man ist noch in der
Pubertät man ist nicht strafmündig ist
aber soll aber bereits mündig sein sein
Geschlecht zu wechseln und vielleicht
sogar auf operable Weise also es war
gegen den Willen der Eltern und das
finde ich das geht nicht also man kann
nicht sagen mit 14 bis zum strafbündig
darf es nicht genug Alkohol trinken
darfst kein Auto fahren keine Verträge
abschließen aber darf ich obere lassen
bis der bis die schwarze Kraft und die
Eltern müssen es nicht mal zustimmen das
finde ich nicht das ist da ein Problem
das ist also meines Wissens ist das noch
in der Schwebe und es gibt auch jetzt
das aktuelle geändert da stand das bis
18 der Eltern zustimmen müssen okay es
kann aber auch eine rechtliche Klärung
also sozusagen hinter einem Gericht
beispielsweise geben wenn sich Eltern
Wille und Kindeswille da wieder
aus dem Elternhaus ausbrechen indem sie
ihre Kinder auf eine auf eine
geschlechtstransistion sozusagen
verklagen das ist der Gesetzentwurf
trägt die Linke denn das neue
selbstbestimmungsgericht mit herboltin
wir tragen das mit und ich glaube man
muss das da differenzieren also es geht
da in diesem Fall ging es um eine
Geschlechtsanpassung transition
hier geht es erstmal um
personenstandsrecht das heißt den
Eintrag kommen
ausweisen
weil das Transsexuellengesetz was wir
jetzt damit abgeschafft wird was
höchstdiskriminierend war da haben sie
recht da hat das
Bundesverfassungsgericht einige Urteile
getroffen beispielsweise die Frage der
Zwangssterilisation
das macht niemand einem freiwillig das
wird einfach auch nicht mehr gemacht das
ist abgeschafft am antworten dann hat
das damals vorgesehen man musste sich
vom Ehepartner am Trennen von seiner
Frau von seinem Mann beispielsweise im
Trend das abgeschafft worden macht auch
heutzutage niemand genauso wie damit mit
den Urteilen des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts insgesamt die
Geschlechtsumwandlung zurückgegangen am
sind und wir wissen aus anderen Ländern
beispielsweise dänemark hat 2014 ein
Selbstbestimmungsrecht einen geführt was
dem deutschen vergleichbar ist und was
das fortschrittlichste
also wir können jetzt mit Ländern nicht
noch eine Beobachtung da anführt da war
es wirklich so wie sie es auch richtig
gesagt haben es betrifft die 99% nicht
aber
waren wenn Frau blank hier sitzt und
davor waren und sagt es macht die Tür
dazu auf verständlich aber es gibt diese
Beobachtung beim Selbstbestimmungsrecht
dass da eben das gegenteilige ist weil
es teilweise den Druck nimmt sozusagen
das heißt ich kann mir den Eintrag
nehmen ich fühle mich als Frau ich muss
aber nicht unbedingt eine gesch
Umwandlung am machen und die
Problematiken hat sie ja da sehr gut und
sehr eindrücklich in ihrer Sendung da
geschildert schon so gerade
es macht die Tür auf sie können das
nicht aber sie sagt aber die Beobachtung
die wir gemacht haben sowohl mit dem
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts und
den Auswirkung
Geschlechtsumwandlung sind dadurch
zurück am gegangen aber aber auch keine
Lust sie einzuladen ich meine wenn ich
dafür wäre es mitteilen würde würde ich
Sie einladen also verschiedene Menschen
sie wissen es ist nicht mein Haupt
Themenfeld ich beschäftige mich vor
allem mit Energie und Klimapolitik aber
ich finde es sehr im interessanter
unterschiedliche Meinungen zuzuhören und
Positionen zu hören ich finde das auch
total wichtig finde es auch gut dass sie
sie eingeladen haben und Diskussion ich
bin nur sagen es sind zwei
unterschiedliche
Ebenen ist ist die Ebene der Geschlecht
Anpassung wo sie ihre Erfahrungen
geschildert hat und das
Selbstbestimmungsrecht und die Erfahrung
aus Dänemark und diese Erfahrung mit dem
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil zeigen
dass es hier eben da nicht zusammen ja
es geht juristisch aber nicht so sehr um
die Betroffenen die Betroffenen haben ja
das Recht und die Betroffenen von einer
geschlechtsidentitätsstörung die haben
natürlich das Recht dass ihnen geholfen
wird und da ist es richtig dass das
Transsexuellengesetz zum Beispiel
abgeschafft werden muss und durch eine
andere Lösung abgelöst werden muss wovon
ich rede sind die 99 Prozent der Bürger
die überhaupt kein Problem mit ihrer
Geschlechtsidentität haben die sich
künftig aber nach Belieben einmal im
Jahr von Mann zur Frau machen können und
zum Frau zu Mann mit allen Rechten mit
allen glauben Sie denn das und wirklich
dann auch gemacht natürlich
von der Gießkanne Mentalität vorhin
gesprochen wir brauchen doch nur den
einen Fall des Missbrauchs das gemacht
wird dass Männer in Schutzräume
eindringen dass Männer juristisch sich
einklagt jetzt auf Krankenhausstationen
für Frauen und ähnliches das sind ganz
praktische Dinge es passiert jetzt schon
aber ich sehe diesen Missbrauch jetzt
dass ich jemand überlegt also diese 99%
von denen sie jetzt gesprochen haben
dass man sein Geschlecht ändert diese
Missbrauch den sehe ich nicht so als das
Problem bei dieser Geschichte sind vor
allem die Teenager die noch nicht so
richtig wissen in welche Richtung geht
es und wenn sie dann die Möglichkeit
haben zwischen einem Geschlechts und so
weiter zu unterscheiden und dann in der
Diskussion zu Hause mit den Eltern sind
und das ist glaube ich in einer in einer
Phase wo man sozusagen sich selber sucht
dass man jetzt vielleicht die
Möglichkeit hat es gibt ja auch schon
pubertätsblocker für Kinder bei total in
Amerika hast du die Situation dass es
das die Kliniken jetzt Boom die diese
Geschlechtsumwandlung schon für Teenager
machen und das finde ich das ist die
gefährliche Entwicklung und nicht das
jetzt jemand wie ich jetzt plötzlich
sage okay nächstes Jahr überlege ich mir
ob ich eine Frau bin um irgendwie einen
Vorteil zu haben
also er ist ganz Zeit ist noch
viel zu holen und wünschen Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend und morgen Abend
werden wieder zurück bei viertel nach
acht tschüss schönen Abend noch
[Musik]